>> Speaker 1: From the Library
of Congress in Washington DC.
>> Jason Steinhauer:
Well, good afternoon.
My name is Jason Steinhaeur.
I'm a program specialist
with the John W. Kluge Center
at the Library of Congress.
Before we begin today's
program, please take a moment
to check your cellphones
and other electronic devices
and please set them to silent.
I'll also make you aware that this
afternoon's program is being filmed
for placement on the Kluge
Center website as well
as our YouTube and iTunes playlists.
I encourage you to visit our
website, loc.gov/kluge, K-L-U-G-E,
to view other lectures delivered
by current and past Kluge scholars.
Today's lecture is presented by the
John W. Kluge Center at the Library
of Congress and cosponsored by the
embassy of the Republic of Bulgaria
as part of the 2016 European
Month of Culture celebrations.
I wish to express our thanks
to the Bulgarian Embassy
and the EU Delegation to United
States for their collegiality
and collaboration this month.
And to mention that in partnership
with the EU, we are featuring
on our blog all month the stories
of European scholars
who've conducted research
at the Kluge Center including
today's speaking Theo Christov,
who is of Bulgarian heritage.
And we are delighted and
honored this afternoon
to have the ambassador from Bulgaria
to United States here with us today.
And so, I'd like to take this
moment to call her Excellency
to offer a few words of welcome.
[ Applause ]
>> Elena Poptodorova:
Good afternoon.
I very well understand
why our master
of ceremonies today did
not dare mention my name.
It can be a tongue twister.
So I will pronounce
for you very dear host,
also because there won't be many
days left for me to pronounce it
out loud in this country.
I'm just about to finish my
tour as ambassador of Bulgaria
to the United States of America
and what a greater opportunity.
I even think if I'm not
mistaken, and I'm not,
this is indeed my last
speaking event.
So, that is to be recorded in my
mind at least and in my heart.
And you will know why I
think it is so special.
It is the event itself,
but, of course,
it falls into a much bigger context.
So, you'll-- if you're here in this
room, you know why you're here.
It is, of course, the very
interesting presentation,
which I've been looking
forward to listening to.
And I must confess some
ignorance, myself, on the subject.
So it's very welcome in
a personal way as well.
But also, you would know that this
is not just a single one time event.
May 9th is the day of Europe.
And luckily, happily Bulgaria is
already part of the European family
of nations, who together
celebrate this date,
this occasion in this
town and elsewhere.
So, it is a coordinated
program of all 28 countries
that happens all over the world.
So, you can imagine what the
rate opportunity it is to be part
of such a massive-- such
a broad reaching effort.
It is also extremely intense
and interesting in this town.
All embassies are engaged in
different cultural programs,
so you have all types of tastes
to be met, to be satisfied.
It is visits through the embassies.
It is cultural programs.
It is the arts.
It is literary programs.
Some-- it is dance.
But I would say that today's event,
which is happily and thankfully part
of the program in cooperation
with probably the most,
I would call it sublime
institution in this country,
which is the Library of Congress,
is the most intellectual
one, the most rewarding one.
And I believe all of us
will only be very happy
to take the benefit
of this presentation.
Why I said that this will be a
much-- and I think-- this might--
few words will be co-located
in a broader context.
I moved in odd, by the fact
that we are holding this event
in this building in cooperation
with the Library of Congress
and the Center, the Kluge
Center and, of course,
the delegation of the
European Union.
The Library of Congress is not
only the institution that it is,
but it has been Bulgaria's
partner for so many years.
And I must confess that I
take not only pride, humility,
but also deep emotion in
having been long time partner
and friend of Dr. Billington.
I think this country and the Library
of Congress have been blessed
to have this tighten
of intellectual thought
and of humane attitude
like Dr. Billington.
We, of course, did not
always deal with the doctor,
with Dr. Billington, I
mean, at that highest level.
We had great partnership with the
different teams here at the Library.
We tried to provide and to
offer here as much as we could
from our own archives, which were
not known and not admitted to travel
to this library and to this country.
So, in so many words, I just really,
really wanted to let you know
that it was not only a protocol
courtesy or a diplomatic language
that I use in saying how
special the event is.
For me, I find it serendipitous,
it's kind of a great,
great conclusion of a great
relationship, of course, personal
but also professional
as my country's ambassador
to this country.
So, I will really be self complacent
or if I would touch presentation
of Theo, because I won't be able
to do it as well as you would.
So, I step away to be
part of the audience.
We're really looking forward
to your presentation, Theo.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Jason Steinhauer:
Thank you so much
for that warm introduction
and welcome.
And it's fitting that you
bring up Dr. Billington
because we are standing in the John
W. Kluge Center, which was brought
to reality by the vision
of Dr. Billington
and the late John W. Kluge.
The Kluge Center is a vibrant
scholar center on Capitol Hill.
And we bring together scholars and
researchers from around the world
to stimulate and energize
one another, to distil wisdom
from the Library's rich
resources and to interact
with policymakers and the public.
We offer opportunities for senior
scholars, post-doctoral fellows
and PhD candidates to conduct
research in the Library
of Congress' collections.
And we also offer free public
lectures, conferences, symposia
and other programs such as this one,
as well as administer
the Kluge Prize,
which recognizes outstanding
achievement
in the humanities and
social sciences.
And as a side note, we are
currently accepting applications
for Kluge fellowships, which is
the fellowship that Theo holds.
For more information
about the center,
please visit loc.gov/kluge,
K-L-U-G-E.
And I invite you sign up for
our RSS email list to learn
about future programs as
well opportunities for you
to conduct your own research
here at the Library of Congress.
So, on to today's program.
Today's program is
titled "The Law of Nations
in America's Independence."
It features scholar Theo
Christov, currently a Kluge fellow
at the John W. Kluge Center.
While at the Library of Congress,
Theo has been working on a project
that situates the early American
republic within the emergence
of the field of international law.
In particular, he exam--
he is examining the connections
between America's independence
and European philosophers
such as Emer Vattel,
about whom we'll hear more today.
Vattel's name is not
well known to us today.
However, in the period of 1789 to
1820, he was the most cited author
in legal documents
and court proceedings
in the early American republic.
And his work was consulted
upon by delegates to the First
and Second Continental Congresses.
Dr. Theo Christov is an
assistant professor of history
and international affairs
at the George Washington University
here in DC, my alma matter.
He is also been a visiting
assistant professor
at North Western University.
He received his PhD
from UCLA in 2008.
And he is the author of "Before
Anarchy: Hobbes and His Critics
in Modern International Thought."
He is also the author of several
book chapters, articles and reviews.
And he has received numerous awards
and fellowships including
the European Society
of International Law
Young Scholar Fellowship,
Phi Beta Kappa International
Student Fellowship, excuse me,
and UCLA Chancellor's Dissertation
Year Fellowship and, of course,
a Kluge Fellowship
here at the Library
of Congress, which
is now completing.
So, please join me in
welcoming Theo Christov.
[ Applause ]
>> Theo Christov: Thank you so much
for that very kind introduction
and a warm welcome
to our ambassador.
Thank you for the kind words.
Before I begin, let me--
can you all hear me?
I would like to thank
the Kluge Center
for these 11 months in residence.
And I especially want to give
a special thanks to Mary Lou,
to Jason, to Travis, to Joan
for all the hospitality as well
as to all the Kluge fellows.
Especially one of them,
I want to recognize,
that would be Will
Slauter [assumed spelling]
for all these wonderful
conversations.
Now, I'm well aware that in
any [inaudible] and asset,
so the first President of the United
States delivered his inaugural
address in just about 135 words,
which was the shortest address,
whereas the 9th President, William
Henry Harrison delivered his speech
in over two and a half hours.
So what I'm going to try to do--
and by the way, for those of you
who don't know he came down with
a flu the next died and he died
of pneumonia within a month.
So with that in mind, I will keep
my remark trip all 45 minutes
and share some thoughts
with you on my research,
which I have been conducting here
for the last nine or 10 months.
And sadly, I have a less
than two months left.
What I'm going to present to you
today is part of ongoing research,
I have conducted at the
Library of Congress.
The larger research asks the
question, how did the world
of states emerge from a
former world of empires?
After all, the existence
of states today is a fact
that we take for granted.
The unprecedented growth of--
in the umber of states since the
mid 20th century has largely been a
product of decolonization in Africa,
in Asia, but forms of sovereignty
which are recognizably
modern have existed
since at least late 18th century.
And the founding of this
country in particular illuminates
at least one significant
point about the creation
of states namely their desire for
independence or domestic sovereignty
but also commitment to
interdependence in their relations
with other states, what I call
international sovereignty.
While writing the genealogy
of the modern statehood can
be approached variously,
the one story I have chosen
to pursue is the birth
of the United States in late
18th and early 19th century.
Such a pursuit is not entirely
arbitrary tracing the origin
of the state back to British North
America in the 1770s allows us
to situate the idea of sovereignty
not only in its domestic,
but especially in its
international context.
And I'll make that more
clear as I move along.
That context can be found in what
was called at that time the law
of nature and nations
and that, which is coming
to be called international law.
And some of you may know that
the term international law was
in fact coined by Jeremy Bentham in
1786 to designate a different way
of thinking about the
Law of Nations.
Such a law was partially normative
for it prescribed how
states ought to behave.
And it was partly conventional
for it was based in convention
and described the established
practices among states.
In my remarks today, I locate
the rising United States
in late 18th century in these two
conceptions of international law,
the normative and the conventional.
And I argue that the American
revolutionaries were making claims
not only for independence from
Britain, but also if not primarily
for interdependence
among other states.
Their ultimate goal was not merely
domestic autonomy, but above all,
external recognition by
other states beyond Britain.
They clearly understood that
independence was their ticket
for admission into the
international community of states,
but the American revolutionaries
would have hardly been able
to accomplish their global
reach had it not been
for a Swiss political thinker
by the name of Emer Vattel,
the name I will be
mentioning in my discussion.
So he is? Born in 1714 in the
Swiss principality of Neuchatel,
Vattel came from a
privilege background.
His father was a high ranking
clergyman while his mother was the
daughter of the treasure
of Prussian King.
His interest in philosophy on his
father's side and taste of politics
on his mother's side
define his passion for both.
His main work, the Law
of Nations published
in 1758 was not envisioned.
And this is a key point.
It was not envisioned to make an
original contribution it was simply
intended to popularize the works
of two German philosophers,
Leibniz and Wolff.
Both of whom had produced
works on the law of nature.
Ingenuous as their works were
and can tell that by the length
of their wigs, they remain largely
inaccessible to wider audience.
Written in Latin, they were full
of mathematical demonstrations
to prove the inclinations
of human nature.
Vattel said, to transform
liveness in Wolff's ideas
in a comprehensible way and
free their cumbersome systems
from securities.
The irony is that while the Law
of Nations was never intended
to be original in its content,
it became an instant classic
and a political guidebook in the
hands of every American statesman.
Britain and Europe exported
across the Atlantic,
the book was so to speak
naturalized in the context
of American independence.
Many of the founding fathers
including George Washington were not
only deeply familiar with the
arguments of the Law of Nations,
but also actively engaged in-- I
mean debates over the consecution.
In this 1796 portrait of George
Washington by Gilbert Stewart,
the painter has carefully
chosen books
that represent Washington's world
of ideas and world of politics,
while Vattel's book is not among
the few depicted in this portrait,
it should have a very lightly
candidate as I'm about to argue.
For a men known for his
diligence and integrity,
it comes as a surprise that he
failed to return two volumes
that were due on November 2nd, 1789,
both from the New York Society
Library, the books were Vattel's Law
of Nations and a collection of works
from Britain's lower
house of parliament.
It was known not until 1934 that
the charge-out ledger was discovered
in the library's basement
and for almost a 150 years no
one could have possibly suspected
the misdeed.
And these are the two
items from the ledger.
Now the other borrowers including
Aaron Burr, Alexander Hamilton,
John Jay all returned
their library books,
but one conspicuous borrower
never returned his two books.
And guess what, he was not even
a paying member of the library.
And unlike the Library of Congress
today, which is absolutely free,
back then Patrons had to in
fact pay annual membership
to be able to check all the books.
So let's hope he Library of
Congress doesn't change that policy.
Now, that patron had an
entree on October 5th, 1789,
which was recorded
simply as president
in the space of the borrower.
Vattel's Law of Nations and volume
12 of the 14 volume collection
of common debates, which
contained transcripts of debates
from the house of commons must
have surely proved indispensable
for a man preoccupied with the
business of creating a new nation
and learning how to
be its president.
Anecdote even has it that the new
president was found consulting
Vattel's book by visitors
on his first day in office
after his inauguration on
April 30th, 1789 in New York,
which was the capital
city back then.
Now, when Philadelphia became the
capital city at the following year
in 1790, he merely took the
book with him never to return
to the library, that is until it
somehow reappeared 221 years later.
The book was eventually returned
from the George Washington's
Mount Vernon Library,
not far from Washington DC to the
New York society library in 2010
with a waived fee of $300,000,
of course, inflation adjusted.
So what could have possibly prompted
the first president who had been
in office for mere five
months to send out a messenger
for his cherry street home
down to New York Society
Library in Federal Hall.
Now, if you turn to the New York
Daily Gazette from October 5th,
1789, which the president must
have almost certainly have read
when he requested a copy of Vattel,
it reads like a global chronicle
of stories covering four continents.
It contains a letter on
the revolutions in Paris,
allusions to the Russians,
the English, the Turkish army,
the State of Holland, the African
prince, a Jamaican planter and,
of course, the general
assembly in Philadelphia itself.
Published as one of two dailies, the
New York Daily Gazette was anything
but local in its coverage and
inclusion of foreign affairs
on its pages merely reflected how
America's saw its place in the world
as a nascent state trying to remain
neutral during your political
turmoil and emerge as a
fully pledge sovereign
of the international stage.
The United States was inextricably
becoming part of a wider world
of customs and conventions
practiced between states.
The work of Vattel provided
indispensable intellectual
ammunition to the defenders
of the republic
for decades surrounding
the birth and adolescence
of the new American nation.
In the hands of the
early republicans,
the Law of Nations written
largely for European audience,
this is a key point, it
served to the two-fold purpose
of justifying war for
independence from the British
and of weaving the unique
American political experience
into the larger fabric of the
European experience of liberty.
It affectively linked ideologically
both sides of the Atlantic.
The seemingly insignificant
discovery
of the book return
neglect reveals less
about the character
of the president.
And let's not forget the never
lying George Washington story
of cutting down the cherry tree.
Then it reveals a [inaudible] about
the European thinkers who would come
to exercise a tremendous
influence on the leading statesmen
of the newly founded country.
Faced with political
and religious turmoil
that threatened the very
fabric of their societies,
many political authors dismantled
all the European monarchical
arguments and fervently
defended a new constitution built
on the right of citizens.
While their argument is in
favor of political models
of legitimate sovereignty
and statehood emerge
from a distinctly intra-European
context of civil and religious wars,
they still can take a very
broad appeal to the universality
of human experience
and rightful demands
for political self governance.
That universality proved critical
in making arguments not only
in defensive domestic autonomy
but also in the promotion
of international sovereignty
including the recognition
of the United States
by outside actors.
In dependent states, the hallmark
of Vattel's legacy must be sovereign
both in relation to themselves,
but also in relation to each other.
So Vattel's treaties served as an
indispensable guidebook in the hands
of the framers including the
first president who consulted it
in situating independence within
the large context of statehood.
It also helped addressed the
question of how a declaration
of independence from Great
Britain served simultaneously
as a proclamation of inter
dependence to the world of states.
Scholarship has generally
tended to acknowledge Vattel
as the most cited author
in legal documents
as Jason mentioned
earlier after 1789.
And especially throughout the
19th century, the story I have
to tell it's a story of
Vattel before and around 1789.
So in the time remaining I
will sketch that pre-1789 story
and reinstate Vattel not only
the preeminent thinker most
authoritative in debates over
the future of this country,
but also I want to argue and I know
this is no small claim to make,
there was-- he was even more gasped,
influential then locked himself.
And I might be being a
little theoretical but if I
in a different version I
would say, Vattel over lock.
That would be the basic claim
that I would want to make today.
Now, Vattel's authority
in this country can be
traced as far back as 1762.
That is the earliest I have
been able to come up with,
which is a quarter of a
century before the drafting
of the constitution itself.
So it's quite a long time.
When Vattel request a copy of
the Law of Nations in 1789,
George Washington-- when George
Washington requested a copy
of Vattel's Law of Nations in
1789, he had already been familiar
with the arguments for independence
long before he became the
first president.
As early as 1773, he
seems to have known about
and almost certainly
have read Vattel's work.
And I have something to
show you to prove that.
In a shipment request
dated October 6th, 1773,
George Washington submitted a list
of authors that included Hutchison,
Ferguson, Grotius, Smith,
Monstequieu and, of course, Vattel.
Fluent in French and verse in Latin
many of the founding fathers engaged
with political writings that derive
their rights and duties of states
from those of individuals placed
in their natural condition
of perfect equality.
The essential analogy
between free persons
and sovereign states provided the
ideal context for making claims
for independence of the
newly formed United States.
From Hobbes to Pufendorf, European
political thinkers preoccupied the
minds of the participants
in the central debate
over justifying revolution
and independence.
Connected by similar experiences
of oppression and dependence,
Europe and American could not
have been brought any closer
in their ideological proximity in
addressing the fundamental question
of how to secure a free
and independent state.
The political theory of John
Locke, whom Jefferson called,
you may be familiar with this,
it's actually here in the Library
of Congress, this is
Jefferson's own writing.
He called the three greatest
men, John Locke was one of them
that ever lived without
any exception.
And by the way, you see
in these circles Bacon
and Newton are the other
two in addition to Locke.
Those three for Jefferson had been--
that it was has been widely
noted and taken for granted.
The alienable rights of life,
liberty and pursuit of happiness
and shrine in the declaration
of independence continually
get attributed to John Locke
and his idea of life,
liberty and state.
But few, if any would link Vattel's
language of rights and sovereignty
with that of the founding document.
This is what I'm trying to do in my
own project, part of the explanation
for the conventional acceptance
of Locke's influence
life and chronology.
Most scholars have tended to
emphasize the influence of Vattel
after the revolutionary war and have
continued to stress the importance,
well, into the present day.
Even the Supreme Court affirmed
as late as 1978 that Vattel was,
I quote, "The international
jurist most widely cited
in the first 50 years
after the Revolution."
Propositions make a
huge difference for me.
So this is after the Revolution.
I'm concerned with
prior to the revolution.
Writing his introduction in
1916 to Vattel's own book,
Albert de La Pradelle concurs
that the fathers of independence,
I quote, "were in a court with the
ideas of Vattel and found his--
in his work all the maxims
of political liberty."
From the mid 1770s, the more
the United States progressed,
the greater became Vattel's
influence, so that in 1780 the Law
of Nations became a classic
textbook in universities.
In fact as early as 1773, it
has been on the curriculum
of King's College or
Columbia University today.
But the history of Vattel's presence
in America extends even further back
by about a decade prior
to the 1760s.
Much realistic knowledge has been
the contribution of his thought
to the intellectual
debates over independence
on the American republic
in the yeas leading
up to the revolution of 1776.
The Law of Nations appeared
first in 1758 French,
one of the first treaties at
that time to have been written
in the vernacular rather
than the widely used Latin.
The first English translation of
the work was published anonymously
in London in 1759, followed by
another English translation in 1760.
Only two years later,
1762 in September.
Vattel's treaties in fact
made its way to New York.
It was imported from London.
It was made available for
purchase from Garrat Noel,
the first New York bookseller
located on Dock Street in Manhattan.
From his shop, Noel also operated
what he called a circulating library
of several thousand volumes of
choice book for those who delight
in reading like all of us.
And almost certain, the Law
of Nations would have been a
monkey [phonetic] circulating book,
which would have made it even more
widely accessible to readership
without the means to
own a copy of it.
John Adams, a delegate to
the Continental Congress
and later the second US
president must have been one
of the very first customers to
have purchase the Law of Nations.
In his diary on February
1st, 1763 or just two months
after the book was made available
on this side of the Atlantic,
John Adams records that after
spending the day frivolously,
you could ask what he was doing,
instead of reading and thinking,
" I employed however, too little
of my time thinking reading.
I might have spent much more."
The idea of Mr. Vattel indeed
scalding and frowning haunted me.
While one they only
speculate which specific idea
of the treaties may have haunted
Adams, it would have been--
it would be possible to
suggest that he may have sought
to appropriate Vattel's arguments
within the larger context
of the imperial crisis over the
future of the British empire
which had brewing since
at least 1763.
In reading Vattel, Adams must
have surely been pretty occupied
with establishing the
proper relationship
between Britain's legitimate
power into colonies
and the rights of the Americans.
Again, the rights of
British subjects
in the imperial periphery
be reconciled
with government at its core.
As one of the most learned
and widely read among
the founding fathers,
Adams had not only read extensively
and was impressed with Vattel,
but he was also deeply familiar
with the works of those compatriots
who had made use of Vattel's ideas.
One of the earliest colonial
defenders to employ Vattel
in political arguments about the
power and limits of parliament
in the case of the colonies
was the Massachusetts lawyer,
James Otis whom the young
Adams both knew and admired.
Educated at Harvard
College, James Otis was--
and I'm quoting here from Adams
himself, "well versed in Greek
and Roman history, philosophy,
oratory, poetry, methology,"
whose "classical studies
had been unusually ardent
and his acquisitions
uncommonly great.
He was considered a great master
of the law of nature and nations
and have read Pufendorf and Vattel."
Arguing the famous assistance case
for five years in the old statehouse
in Boston in 1761 and challenging
the authority of parliament
on behalf of 53 boss and merchants.
Otis made a dramatic speech holding
that ultimately the
general rich were contrary
to both natural law
and English practice.
The 26 year old Adams was present as
described during the actual speech
and was so impressed
with what he have heard
that he described the events on
56 late year later as I quote,
"The first scene of the
first act of all position
to the arbitrary claims
of Great Britain.
Then and there the child
independence was born."
This was Adams almost close
to the end of his life.
Vattel has soon emerged
as a political thinker whose
treaties provided grounds
for resistance against
arbitrary of power.
And he would subsequently
get incorporated
into the larger discourse
on the origin of government.
Otis explained in his-- expanded
his argument in the colonists,
this is in his work
called the rights
of the British colonist
asserted and proved of 1764.
And he extensively cited
the position of Vattel
to support the authority of
parliament of Great Britain
that that authority is in fact
circumscribed by certain balance
which if exceeded their acts
become those of mere power
without right and consequently void.
Such a doctrine is agreeable to
the law of nature and nations
and Vattel was quoted,
"As the authority
on the subject rights are derived
from nature not from consent."
And as Vattel had shown, any
violation of the constitution
of natural law amounted
to a breach of contract.
Critics of the very idea of consent
objected to the voluntary nature
of civil government dismissed
such argument as merely I quote,
"Chimerical and unsupported
by reason and experience."
And quote.
"Already born into the
political compact of society,
citizens may not renounce the
very protection that bites--
that binds them together."
And here is what Otis says
about Vattel, I quote,
"Those who want a full answer to the
question of why consent is the base
of any political community
may consult, not John Law,
but may consult Mr.
Vattel on the law of nature
and their consciousness."
The reference to Vattel in
support of the basic claim
that any political government rest
on the consent of its citizens,
and when that trust has been
violated, they have the right
to resist is unequivocally
endorsed as the voice of reason.
Otis's inclusion of Vattel
in the ranks of Locke
and other major political thinkers
would baptize the Swiss jurors
as the spokesperson for resistance
against British rule and in support
of waging a just war against it.
The reliance on Vattel as
the indisputable authority
in the major pamphlet of the
American revolution paved the way
as early as 1764 for a long
trajectory of his influence
on how the revolutionary framed
their arguments for independence.
Vattel's argument in
defense of political liberty
and independence was not confined
to political pathway theories
in New England nor localized
or publish in Boston.
Later in the same year, it had
spread south to North Carolina,
the last remaining original colony
to acquire a printing press.
And it's customary with most
newspapers at that time,
it was filled with
extensive extracts when works
of religious writers and historians
as well as essays and text
of important legislative acts.
In this July 1764 issue,
a lone history
of the Roman Empire was
began and convenient
for several succeeding installments
only to be followed in September
by a celebration of a
genius whose book I quote,
"is reckoned among the first
for learning and rendition
and sound reasoning," unquote.
It is not entirely incidental
that commentaries on Roman history
and Vattel's Law of Nations
appeared consecutively.
Both of them consider
liberty and autonomy
as foundational to a free society.
Now, the central theme of the
review of the Law of Nations,
which you will see despite
the inclusion of long various
and carefully selected extracts
is the nature of sovereignty,
who possesses political authority
in a civil society whose
end is public happiness.
While the priest [phonetic] derived
his authority from the nation
and the words of the learned
author who has strictly
and simply invested
him with sovereignty,
his regal prerogatives are limited
to the well being of his subjects
and regulated by the
fundamental laws.
Roman history shows that when
supreme authority such as
that of Nero has been abused and
its holder becomes discouraged
of the state and effectively a
public enemy, then the nation may
and ought to defend itself.
So in other words, the argument
I'm making is that this review
of the Law of Nations as early as
1764 has been engaged with not only
in New England but is really
moving south in North Carolina.
And the main argument essentially is
that obedience to authority is based
on the consent of the governed.
It is established for
their common good.
And Vattel is used as a preeminent
authority to defend that argument.
Now, during the First and Second
Continental Congress which convened
between 1774 and 1781 delegates
from all 13 colonies convened
to decide on their future.
Benjamin Franklin who
had put his idea
for such a meeting knew
his Vattel quite well.
Thanks to someone who has remained
in my view the most
acknowledge inspiration
for the American Revolution.
And that is the-- in fact I
was not able to find his--
in fact, so obscure this
person that in fact I've not--
have not been able to find an image.
And I cannot show you an image.
I tried quite a bit on-- find
any images of him on the internet
and I have not been
able to find any.
Who is he?
He was a Frenchman or at
least he was born a Frenchman,
but he resided in the
Hake [phonetic].
He was the first American spy
who was hired by the Americans
but he lived in the Hake.
His name was Charles Dumas.
Now who is Charles Dumas?
He was acting as a secret agent of
the American colonies at the Hake
and he designed the first
revolutionary diplomatic cipher
to mask correspondence between
the Continental Congress
and its foreign agents in Europe
and devoted his life to the cause
of the American independence.
In fact in the view of the
first American judge to serve
on the permanent court
of the international--
of international justice, Dumas
described as, and I quote,
"With the exception of Adams,
Franklin and Jay, Dumas rendered
to the American cause in
Europe services more important
than did any other man."
Versed in the ancient classics, and
skilled in many modern languages,
Dumas edited the original 1758
edition of Vattel's Law of Nations
and sends Frankin three copies
in French in that same year
with the instruction to distribute,
I quote, "One for your own library,
another for that in Philadelphia
and third for such other library
and colony as you may choose."
That is he's referring to Franklin.
Now, an ardent support of
the American revolutionaries
and their struggles for independence
although he himself never crossed
the Atlantic, Dumas edited the
Law of Nations specifically
to aid his American friends
and de facto employers
in their revolt against the British.
He reinvigorated Vattel's arguments
for independence and brought
out the relevance of the
idea of external sovereignty
in the context of the
Law of Nations.
Statehood demands independence
internationally.
The three copies of the Law
of Nations were considered
a most timely gift according
to Franklin's biographer James
Parton, which was, and I quote,
"pounced upon by studious members
of Congress, groping their way
without the light of precedents."
Now, upon-- In Philadelphia,
Franklin wrote to Dumas
in December 19th, 1775 and allow
me to read this long letter.
Now this is again from-- this
is the words of Franklin.
"I am much obliged by the kind
present," he's referring to Dumas,
"you have made us of
your edition of Vattel.
It came to us in good
season, when the circumstances
of a rising state make
it necessary frequently
to consult the Law of Nations.
Accordingly, that copy which
I kept, after depositing one
in my own library and sending
the other to the college
of Massachusetts Bay,
Harvard University,
as you directed has been continually
in the hands of the members
of our congress, now sitting, who
are much pleased with your notes
and preface, and have
entertained a high
and just esteem for their author.
Your manuscript is also
well relished and may
in time have its effect," unquote.
Now, the fate of the
copy that Franklin kept
for himself is not known.
The second Harvard copy of Dumas
Vattel contains a handwritten
commentary written by Dumas himself
in which he shares his idea
upon government and royalty
and effectively endorses
the urgency of Vattel
to the American context
of independence.
In practicable an consequently used
and dangerous to discuss in Europe,
Dumas says, "I thought
that sowed in America,
the Law of Nations would
take root there germinate
and fructify one day."
Now, the third copy that Dumas
sent was presented by Franklin
to the Library Company
of Philadelphia.
On October 10th, 1775, the minute
from the library's director reads,
"Should you may having presented
the library with a very late edition
of Vattel's law of
nature and nations,
the board direct the
secretary to return
that gentleman their
thanks," unquote.
Now, of all three copies, the third
one must almost certainly have been
most heavily used namely the copy
used by the Continental Congress.
And one important reason why
the delegates of the First
and Second Continental Congress
chose to meet in Carpenters Hall,
this is the image of
Carpenters Hall around 1774.
The reason why they chose, I think,
and this might be a little bit
of a stretch, so I'll take
any accusations or any attacks
that may come from you, but I think
the reason why they chose to meet
in Carpenters Hall
is for simple reason,
the building also has the
Library Company of Philadelphia.
Its librarians, Francis Damon
[assumed spelling] reported
that Vattel was one of
the main sources consulted
by delegates during the
First Continental Congress,
which met from September
5th to October 26th, 1774.
And I quote, this is the librarian
of the Library Company
of Philadelphia.
"Philadelphia has become
another Cairo," he wrote,
"with this difference that the one
is a city swarming with merchants,
the other with politician
and statesmen," unquote.
They debated like philosopher for--
by what I was told and this
is him again, "Vattel locked
and Montesquiei seemed to be
standards to which refer either
when settling the rights of
colonies or when a dispute arises
on the justice of propriety
of a measure," unquote.
The Library Company already owned a
copy of the 1760 English translation
of the first French edition of 1758,
which may have been received
at any time before 1763.
So in other words, all I'm saying
is there's multiple variants
and editions being
distributed and circulated.
The authority of Vattel
on questions on the Law
of Nations had thus been well
established by the early 1770s.
A few months prior to
the congressional debates
in December 28, 1773 letter from
the Library Company of Philadelphia
to Benjamin Franklin it stated,
I quote, "the books enclosed
within wire lattices are kept in one
large room and there are available
to be consulted by
delegates," unquote.
By the time Dumas own copy of
Vattel reached Philadelphia in 1775,
the earlier English translation
from 1760 had already been
in such heavy use by statesmen
that it have been rebound
with more modern kind
of paper than that upon
which the book was
originally printed.
The study of the Law of
Nations by the delegates
of the Continental Congress whose
task was in Franklin's language
to inquire into the
circumstances of arising state,
and rising is the key
point I'm making.
Reflected simply the spirit of the
declaration of independence itself,
its central assertion that
governments are instituted
to fulfill the inalienable rights
of life, liberty and pursuit
of happiness owed intellectual
debt to Vattel's own argument
on legitimacy for our people
overthrow a tyrannical sovereign.
Governments may not-- may not
be usurping the transient--
and governments may not be usurp
for transient and trivial causes,
but they can be overthrown
after a long chain of abuses
of their own basic
political and social rights.
After repeated appeals to the
British brethren who remained deaf
to the voice of justice
and consanguinity,
the Americans were prepared
to declare their independence
from the British ground
with a full right
of a sovereign government truly--
to levy war, conclude peace,
contract alliances and establish
commerce and to do all other acts
and things, which independent
states may of right do.
The Law of Nations, the book
not only a short legitimacy
to the claims for independence,
it also provided a blueprint
for the practice of statehood
in the world of sovereigns.
The newly founded United States in
a confluence of early intended acts
and fortunate circumstances
will become the first state
to make international independence
the whole mark of statehood.
Like all the other founding fathers
who did not demarcate the domestics
fear from that of the foreign,
Jefferson, and by the way, this
building is named after him,
he accumulated nearly all
treatises on the subject
of natural law Grotius, Pufendorf,
Wolff and, of course, not one
but two different editions
of Vattel's Law of Nations.
Jefferson's copy of Vattel's
later edition which he loan
to representative from
North Carolina
and to another representative
from Rhode Island reveals
that the cross-- that he cross
reference Vattel on the Law
of Nations with the work
of the German juror
George Fredrickson Martins
[assumed spelling].
In referencing Vattel's
work to that of Bodin,
the 16th century political theorist,
Jefferson positioned the theory
of domestic sovereignty within
the larger context of relations
between independent states.
Sovereignty as independence, the
main justification for waging a war
against British oppression was
located into the larger context
of relations between states and the
law of nature as applied to them.
In bringing my story to an end,
allow me to draw three
main conclusions.
The first one should be
quite obvious by now, mainly,
that far from being marginal and
irrelevant, marginal at best,
irrelevant at worst, Vattel was
in fact at the heart of debate
in the early American republic over
the core ideals of the revolution
that produced a political
conditions for life, liberty
and the pursuit of happiness.
While many of us are
continually reminded of the impact
of John Locke's political
theory exercise on the birth
of this nation, and
I'm not denying that,
the authority of Vattel was
significantly I think far more
reaching and far more lasting.
Vattel over lock, conclusion one.
Second conclusion, it isn't a
way a corollary of the first,
while we consistently regard
independence as the hard one price
of the revolutionaries
and I'm not denying that.
I think in fact it
was interdependence
that was central to their ideology.
They had to become independent
in the first place in order
to realize their independence
in a world of states.
They did so by making use of
available language of the Law
of Nations, a language which
Vattel so conveniently yet,
conclusion number two, so
unintentionally provided to them.
In short the boundary between home
and abroad was merely imaginary.
Americas have always been
part of a much larger world.
The third conclusion, and this
is the final conclusion I want
to leave you with, how we should
transform our understanding
of the American revolution.
Unlike the French revolution,
which has always been regarded
as truly international in its reach,
the American Revolution
has generally
and there has been recent changes
in scholarship on this point,
that American revolution has
generally been seen as the marking
of the birth of a new nation.
And I'm not denying that story,
but the story I have told you
today should unsettle this very
common belief.
It was not simply a domestic
revolution for independence,
it was primarily the
beginning of the modern state.
Writing in 1963, the political
thinker, very prominent,
Hannah Arendt writes and I quote,
"The sad truth of the matter is
that the French Revolution,
which ended in disaster
has made world history,
while the American Revolution,
so triumphantly successful
has remained an event
of little more than
local importance."
The American Revolution as
I've to show was an event
of a truly global significance whose
effects can be felt with us today.
Ironically none of these effects
were in any way intended by Vattel
and yet he would gratefully take
credit for them as he should.
Thanks for the attention.
[ Applause ]
So, we should probably take the
floor and open it questions.
I think we have at least 10 minutes
for any questions that
anyone may have.
Yes, Kennedy?
>> Kennedy: That was terrific.
And you persuaded me that
Vattel is a crucial figure
in American Revolution.
I want to bring us back to
the open remarks you made,
however in your lecture,
and think in this way,
Vattel talks about
nations in a context
of nature as I understand it.
And he talks about state, he doesn't
talk about nations [inaudible].
And particularly my question is
how we get from these categories
of nations and states and impart
the distinction that we can gather
in 20th, we nation states and
[inaudible] this distinction
that is embedded in the
arguments of Vattel [inaudible]
or is it something
that comes a little--
>> Theo Christov: Great question.
That's really the heart
of what I'm trying to do,
how we transition from
empire to states.
Let me just say what
Vattel is not doing.
Vattel is not endorsing
any imperial ways
of perpetuating the European
experience of empires
in the 18th century,
he speaks of nations.
And actually he speaks of
patriarch in the French edition.
So he-- he's very much
thinking in terms of homelands.
He's not thinking in terms
of the nation and state
as we would understand it today.
Now, that is not to say that the
revolutionaries were not making use
to their own ends, and part
of my argument is there have
been unintended consequences
of using Vattel for purposes of
claiming independence in order
to claim interdependence
among other states.
So in other words what
I'm trying to say is
that Vattel's argument is
being used to make claims
for external sovereignty.
But in order to make a claim
for external sovereignty,
you have to have a claim
to domestic sovereignty.
And the thing we've lost track of
the second part of the equation,
we focus so much on domestic
independence and sovereignty,
we've lost track of the
external sovereignty.
I think what Vattel is doing is he's
giving us the legitimacy criteria
according to which
we can make a claim
for how a state can become an
equal member of the international
and I don't like to use
the word society of states,
but essentially what he is doing
is enumerating the conditions
on which we can claim independence.
And he's making that
argument on various point,
I'm not going to go too much into
it, but he's making distinction
between free persons
and free states,
that there is an analogy
between the two.
That analogy breaks down
because free persons come
and institute society, but free
states don't necessarily come
and institute a global society.
But I think what is critical is
that Vattel speaks of independence
as a condition for interdependence.
And I think that part
of the argument is taken
up by the early Americans.
So I think your point is well taken
that we have to be careful to speak
of nation states in the 20th century
and perhaps even how those
nation states are being unsettled
by non state actors.
But I do think Vattel's approach
of taking interdependence
as a consequent-- consequence
of independence is critical
that we have to start
with independence
and then move on to interdependence.
I hope that answers
part of the question.
Yes?
>> How, you know, how does this
comfort with interdependence
that you've spoken off square
with Washington's ammunition
the steer clear
of national attachments
on the [inaudible]?
>> Theo Christov: Right.
So I think what all of
these Washington, Franklin,
Adams are doing is reading very
carefully Vattel as opposed
to they are endorsing every
single aspect of his theory.
But I think in doing so, Vattel
really serves as an authority.
And I've had conversations with the
other colleague fellow Will Slauter
on the question of how Vattel
is being used as an authority.
And I can say a little
bit more about that
in a more extended answer, but
let me just say briefly that,
what is a question of
authority and how Vattel
in late 18th century is being
used as a political authority?
And the really thing he's
being used as a source
for intellectual ammunition, there
is a bit of a cherry picking going
on in the sense that whatever is
being convenient from his treaties
in his theory, he is being used by
many of the frames to make arguments
that would be useful to their ends.
But fundamentally I think he's
being used as an authority
and he's eventually addressed
as he's just the authority.
I mean, Locke is another one
and Montesquieu is another one,
but Vattel is a true authority
in the Law of Nations.
So I do think that Washington--
there is a certain selectivity
in which he is being used.
And by the way, there's a lot
more engagements of correspondents
that I just couldn't
really gage into.
But that sort of-- that
there is a selective process
in which he's being used.
[Inaudible].
[ Inaudible Remark ]
Yes.
The British loved Vattel
for one simple reason
because he really made very
important the question of commerce
and how the British have
established commercial relations,
which needs to be replicated
in the rest of Europe.
The French did not like Vattel.
And in fact, he was published
in Amsterdam and London.
The very first edition was
published in Neuchatel.
Although I've-- from
what I have read,
it's even questionably first
published in Neuchatel,
but in 1759 an anonymous editor
publishes the work in London.
I don't think that's insignificant
and he praises the British
because one simple reason,
in addition to the fact
that they develop commercial
relations, British love liberty
in a way that no other nation does.
And I think it's very
critical for him
that he doesn't endorse the French,
he doesn't endorse even the Swiss,
he himself is a Swiss,
he's from Neuchatel.
And by the way, he's a
contemporary of Rosso,
but yet he's very much engaging with
the British because they provide
that blueprint for liberty.
So I do think that he's very
much embraced on the island,
but within continental Europe,
he's much more questionable.
And I think this also a very
interesting point to make,
how he's being used and how
his theory has been transformed
in the American context.
He was not writing for the Americans
and yet in the hands, precisely,
of the editor Charles Dumas, he
was able to be very much used here.
And the first part
of the question was
that on any relation with Grotius?
So Grotius was the early
17th century Dutch jurist
and Vattel comes about a
130, a 140 years later.
It's a very interesting question
because Grotius in many ways is seen
as much more rigid on the
question of intervention.
Vattel on the other hand is--
although that's even
somewhat questionable,
but I think he's much more reserved
on the question, can intervention
within international
relations is that permissible.
I think in general Vattel would say
no at least in relation to Grotius.
What connects both
Grotius and Vattel
and by the way there's also a third
name Pufendorf because in 1785,
Immanuel Kant writes of all three of
them, Grotius, Pufendorf and Vattel
as sorry comforters, why?
Simply because they were not--
they were simply very fanciful
with their legal theories
because you cannot
put them in practice.
I think it's a struggle
we have today.
Can international law be
imposed or is simple chimerical?
According to Immanuel Kant,
they were simply chimerical.
So Grotius, Vattel and Pufendorf was
the three he calls sorry comforters,
because they're just comforting us,
but actually we should feel sorry
for that because they're not
really providing anything.
But Grotius is very much
I think coming out of--
and I have actually a reason
to say this, he's really coming
out of use especially in 19th
century because citations,
Vattel in the 19th century in
legal-- in the Supreme Court cases,
in legal proceedings
far exceed those
of Grotius and Pufendorf combined.
So I think the legacy of
Grotius is still there,
but I think question
is practical use.
This was a practical guidebook,
Americans really needed
that guidebook to kind of
struggle with questions
of diplomatic practice,
relations with other states,
Vattel provided that for them.
And I think that kind of
practicality aspect unlike Grotius
who was much more embedded
in his context of Portuguese
versus Spanish imperial rivalry
was much more distance and kind
of less practical than
someone like Vattel.
One more question?
Yes?
[ Inaudible Remark ]
So yeah. Let me-- And I think
it's a very good point to kind
of end some of my remarks.
The question, how can we think
of the rise of the American--
of the United States as
the emergence of the kind
of modernly recognizable
modern system?
Often times, at least in
historiography, people take six
and 48 as that kind of foundational
year that that was when the treaty
of his failure-- the treaties
of his failure were signed.
And I think there's a good
reason to have a marking point.
Periodization [phonetic]
is always nice.
But I think there's lot of issues
with that six and 48 date namely
that Washington starts to
think that this is the birth
of the nation state as
often times especially
in international relations.
Scholarship people
take that birth date
as unequivocally unambiguously
central.
I think there's issues with
that because it's not really
until the question
of how independence
provides the first condition
for external recognition.
And in many ways that's what
I'm trying to argue in my point
that you cannot establish
external recognition,
meaning outside recognizing you
as a state before you claim
domestic autonomy of a certain kind.
Now, there's very-- various ways
in which one can establish political
autonomy and I think someone
like Vattel is more reserved
about how he should structure
our political system.
He's open to various kinds
of political systems
and political regimes.
What is critical is to establish the
conditions for domestic sovereignty,
then and only then external
recondition can be demanded.
And that's exactly what I think
people like David Armitage
for instance have insisted
the declaration
of independence is a legal document
in relation to international law.
How the birth of what we can call
today international law began by way
of moving from independence
to interdependence.
In other words, you're not simply
on autonomous entity existing
on your own, but you're in
relation in a sort of web
of relations with other states.
And I think the birth of the
United States provides that kind
of pivotal moment because
in many ways, let's face it,
America was a fortunate
circumstance,
because nature favored
them in many ways.
And I think that fortunate
circumstance provided the impetus
for how in the 19th and
especially in the second half
of the 20th century the number of
states would quadruple from about 50
around the time that the founding
into United Nations
to almost 200 today.
And I think Vattel is providing that
kind of prescriptive model moving
from independence to
interdependence.
He's also very explicit
that independence is can sometimes
be very violent and very bloody.
It then can go on for sometime.
But once you have accomplished that,
then you are in a position to--
in my sort of words, you have
gained your ticket of admission
into that kind of larger
international society of states.
And the reason why I kind of
brought this story of the emergence
of the state in the
American context is largely
because I think it
provides that momentum
for thinking how a very fortunate
nation has come in late 18th century
by sometimes [inaudible]
circumstances to emerge
as a global actor on
the international stage,
an event which doesn't
really happen until--
really until the late
19th, early 20th century.
But I do think you can already begin
to see how in late 18th century,
there is some manifestations of that
desire to emerge as an equal act
or on the international stage.
Yeah.
>> Jason Steinhauer:
We'll stop there.
>> Theo Christov: Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
>> Speaker 1: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.